[Music]
the symphony of extremes is as diverse
as Finland itself I cut open an cellist
and songwriter a Finnish band
Apocalyptica based the music on DNA
samples from his countryman these people
in Helsinki have never heard the
symphony but they suspect what it might
sound like music from Finnish DNA would
probably be kind of sad and melancholy
like a lot of Finnish people are well I
don't really know what to think about
that I don't know too much about the the
idea anyway but yes those fun if it
sounds like Finnish people and they're
like the Finnish people soul it's gonna
be a pretty heavy
eckhart openen is the most prominent
member of Apocalyptica for years the
cello metal band has been one of
Finland's most popular musical exports
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
toponym is quickly recognized when he
walks through the streets of helsinki
he's composed dozens of songs for
Apocalyptica but he's never used genetic
material as an inspiration before it
took him a while to get used to the idea
for the symphony of extremes writing
music from out of DNA it's kind of I
don't know what it means to be honest
that was my first thought but then I
thought that actually the idea sounds
very interesting and that's why I
decided to start to figure out what what
it could be and what it actually means
there were so many different
possibilities to approach the whole idea
that I that's why I fell it's a big
challenge and therefore I wanted to be
part of it Finland is a country of
contrasts and Lapland the Midnight Sun
shines for 70 consecutive days in winter
there's no Sun at all for more than 50
days straight Eastern and Western Finns
look more different than German and
British people do most of Finland's five
and a half million inhabitants live in
the south
the north of the country is almost empty
at Helsinki's Institute for molecular
medicine Finland scientists have spent
years studying Finnish DNA researcher
yana Sarila and her colleagues
constantly uncover typical variants at
the margins of the country we know that
there are some variants in in the
finnish genome that are more common in
in the northern part of finland or more
common in the western part of finland or
eastern part of finland the differences
are not huge but if you look at the
right regions in the genome you can
actually tell from which part of the
finland finnish individual is from data
composer Jonathan Middleton who teaches
at Finland's Tampere University
translated these DNA variants into
simple sequences of musical notes i
kotappa Ninh then spent long hours in
his studio combining those sequences to
express a sense of Finland
for me it was also important to
understand the mental genetics of
Finnish people and and the history of
the of the nation and where we come from
and and why finished DNA is so diverse
and I also wanted to bring into the
music the field that I my main goal was
that when Finnish people they hear the
this piece that they feel it's very
famous and that was for me equally
important than than these leather chains
you know because this is dnh and they're
basically just letters and nothing else
Chopin and worked hard to ensure that
the various regions of Finland could be
recognized within the music this is
maybe kind of north you know the tundra
with a lot of space era space and
gladness and stuff
[Music]
this is the this directly to from one Y
chromosome Jane the symphony of extremes
has now premiered in Helsinki and
Finnish audiences can find out if they
can recognize their own DNA in the music
you